whether he's playing a Jedi or the
director of shield samuel l.jackson
always follows his instincts and those
instincts are often funny sometimes
though his jokes aren't entirely on
purpose that leads to some outrageous
bloopers and outtakes both for himself
and his co-stars here are some times
when he cut loose Nick Fury is a serious
serious man samuel l.jackson you know
not so much but the guy is such a
professional he manages to keep it
serious even when everyone else around
him is screwing up by going over here to
see him on the thing and tell him you
know don't be going all stealth mode
mode we can't see the 2017 action flick
the hit man's bodyguard gave fans a
chance to see Deadpool and Nick Fury
together at last
well at least the actors who played them
so it's no surprise that there were a
lot of casualties in the film
what is a surprise is that there were
some casualties behind the scenes as
well such as this poor dude poor mace
windu he should have been the ultimate
hero but instead he got blown out a
window thanks to Anakin's betrayal at
least jackson was able to have some fun
with it though filming it over and over
again while pretending the safety mat
was a big comfy mattress and his death
was just a bad dream even though he's
known for playing a guy with one eye
Jackson seems to have amazing peripheral
vision or something because in this
blooper from XXX the return of xander
cage he seems to know exactly what's
happening behind him because soldiers
are built to take orders and fight wars
but we my friend are not at war a war
behind us it can't be easy for Maria
Hill the deputy director of shield under
taskmaster Nick Fury and it can't be
easy for actress Cobie Smulders either
as like Fury himself
Jackson is always watching and ready to
pounce on any screw-up confusing my
eyeline I think I like directly into
camera
okay you just forgot to learn now you
trying to make him some others in the
2003 action flick SWAT Jackson plays a
Los Angeles Police Department sergeant
tasked with putting together an elite
force but only if he can keep his
balance first some rumors about you and
your old partner just like in swats
samuel l.jackson plays a tough-as-nails
cop in the 2010 comedy the other guys
and like in swat gravity is his downfall
that's in the fact that co-stars Wayne
the rock Johnson seems to have no idea
what Jackson is doing whoops tuck and
roll when you hear check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stars
are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]